[Music]
[Applause]
uh Dan Wiki good to have him back on
Lakers beat reporter for the LA Times
covers the NBA if I told you three
months ago Dan
this is what we would be talking about
you would have said what
I would have said Dan you're a crazy
person yeah that this is you have maybe
had some sort of uh head injury or
something like that that this would not
have been it's funny I ran into Thomas
Bryant um yesterday at Denver practice
and you know he requested a trade from
the Lakers around the trade deadline
ended up in Denver and you know he asked
how I was doing and I said I'm still
surprised that I'm here
and here we know the two of us kind of
had a big laugh about that because you
know the storyline for the Lakers for
most of the Season wasn't like can this
team become a contender it was like can
this team get into the playing
tournament yeah like I spent a lot of
time this year running sort of
tiebreakers for 12th Place
and it you know it happened pretty
quickly where you know the team just
started winning three or four games all
the time you know and just kind of all
right well they're not 12th anymore now
they're 10th and now they're not 10th
anymore and now they're they could maybe
be Fifth and you know they ended up in
seventh place but they were playing
really good basketball
and they've been healthy and they've you
know they've been the best defense in
the NBA since the trade deadline they've
been the best defense
you know in the league in the playoffs
at this point I I probably should stop
being surprised I don't know that I
fully have embraced that part of it yet
I still think that
you know it's kind of wild that my
season professionally is still going
yeah I was wasn't I thought I'd be in
Chicago for the draft combine to see
where women yam ended up I didn't think
I'd be in Denver but
I'm in Denver
why is it LeBron the GM failed but then
Rob polinka the GM saved the season so
LeBron doesn't get any CR he gets blamed
but he doesn't get any credit for what
happened at the trade deadline is uh is
is that a fair fair approach to this
story yeah I think so I mean I think
there was a fair amount of sort of hand
washing of the GM duties um post
Westbrook that like that was a trade
that nobody really wanted credit for
um pretty quickly and so a lot of people
kind of Step Back From the table and I
think you know LeBron's role as a
decision maker and this wasn't you know
go get me D'Angelo Russell it was more
like let's fix this I want to fix this
and you know it wasn't totally clear
what the Lakers were gonna do they ended
up you know the first shot was kind of
trading for rui hachimura and it was
like okay well maybe they're going to be
aggressive and you know we got down to
it and then they got they take part in
this big massive trade with Russell
Westbrook where they bring in what at
the time was three starters for them
um Beasley has since moved to the bench
and they completely revamped their
roster and you know they totally changed
their season I think that I think they
were six games under 500 on the day of
the trade deadline and you know they
lost that night to Milwaukee they only
had like seven players and then they
beat the Warriors in Golden State the
following day and it was been kind of
Off to the Races since then
Mike Brown did a wonderful job in
Sacramento but I thought yep Darvin ham
quietly did a spectacular job with this
roster and and he's always struck me as
a guy who's not asking for credit he's
not a notice me guy flamboyant in any
way he's just you're gonna come in
you're gonna play the way I want you to
play and that means you play defense and
you play tough why hasn't Darvin ham
maybe gotten his flowers as the kids
like to say
yeah the kids do like to say that Dad
I'm I I can tell you I'm very much in
touch with the with the lingo out there
uh I I think
um a couple things I think you know he
he was actually
pretty routinely criticized at times
throughout the season among Laker fans
for things like lack of adjustments in
games yeah
um I think John Moran had a 26 Point
quarter or something like that against
the Lakers and they could never really
turn the faucet off
um I but I think a lot of what darvin's
done incredibly well has been more
spiritual it's been more um he's a
consistent positive person
um consistency is the the thing I
remember when I spoke to Mike boudinos
when he got hired that was the thing
that that he stressed to me most was
that
um pardon me when Darwin ham got hired
with the Lakers was Bud said like you
see this guy and you're like there's no
way he can be this way every day and
then you're with them for six years and
you're like oh my God he's this way
every day and you know he's tough but
he's caring
um he's someone you like wouldn't want
to challenge but at the same time he's
someone who will you know will give you
a a big hug and and embrace you when you
need to be embraced and he kind of walks
that line it it's funny you know
um there was a running joke early in the
season because Darwin had said something
like you know this isn't about W's and
L's it's about wisdoms and lessons
and the joke among Laker fans and some
of the writers was like it looks like
we're headed to like a 50 lesson season
maybe 32 wisdoms and and you know but
it's funny as he said it the other day
and it didn't it didn't hit the same way
it was like oh yeah you know like this
is a team that's been through a ton and
they play like a team that has been
through a ton well he's leading the
league in wisdom
yes yes they've worked their way and do
more wisdom than lessons it looked like
for sure it was gonna be way more
lessons and no and they've they've built
I I think a really strong identity and
they've taken on toughest and defense
which are certainly the traits that he
used to become a success in the NBA and
in a lot of ways that's the biggest Mark
of a successful coach is like does your
team look like you
Dan Wiki is uh covering the Lakers in
Denver for the LA Times also covers the
NBA how good is Denver
they've been the best team in the west
since early December and
um you know I think a lot of us in the
media and I was probably guilty of this
at times to have been kind of trying to
invent ways for them to not be the best
team in the west
um where it seemed like oh who's gonna
knock them off is Memphis more dangerous
is it going to be Phoenix like certainly
it's going to be Phoenix after the trade
deadline it always seemed like there
there was sort of an invention of a team
that like that there wasn't a lot of
faith in Denver quite frankly because
they've they've been this kind of team
before they've been this kind of team
before by the way even in previous
iterations you know where they're just
like they win at altitude in the regular
season it's a horrible place to play and
and you know they're good it's probably
good for five or six wins and and then
come play off time that that tends to
level up
um they've been the most consistent team
in this league since December minus the
late season lull they've got a star like
a star star capital letters and Nicola
jokic uh Jamal Murray has worked his way
back into pre-acl form and they have
size on the wings and they have an
incredible offense and they have a
pretty good defense like it makes really
good sense Dan that they are in this
position
um that being said like I still think
there are people out there that are like
kind of like okay well like now let's
see let's test them now like like
beating Phoenix wasn't enough of a uh um
a mark on on their season wasn't enough
to kind of validate this group but to me
I look at Denver and I see it I see a
team certainly capable of winning the
championship Lakers will win if
I think if Anthony Davis is better than
Nicola jokic on both ends of the floor I
think that's the biggest thing is like
obviously we know how Nicola can impact
the game offensively
um canadi have sort of jokic-ish games
defensively where where you just kind of
watch it and I what I mean by that is
there was a game earlier this year Dan
where nicolio could shot five times
against the Lakers and he was by far the
best player on the court and you just
felt it watching it it was crazy to see
him sort of marionette his way through a
basketball game 80's done that on
defense a lot in Missouri I really did
it in the first round got stretched a
little bit more against the Warriors but
I think kind of you know when it came
time to close them out was you know just
again a master on that side of the ball
if he can do that against the Denver
team that that quite frankly doesn't
shoot a ton of Threes that wants to kind
of challenge inside
um if he can be that kind of an impact
player I I think the Lakers can win the
series
what should we know about Victor 1
bayama is he a generational Talent
you should know that when you sit down
to watch him you will wonder how this is
all possible
um I saw him in Las Vegas this um
preseason when he kind of came over with
his French team to play the g-league
ignite and uh I remember watching him
just kind of moving warm-ups and you're
just like you you want to like almost
adjust the your eyes like the TV screen
to be like the no the ratios are off
here like this is not normal to see
somebody who is this big like I mean I
saw him stand next to Rudy go Baron I
mean he is bigger than Rudy gobert
um but then you watch him dribble and
shoot and it's like like he looks like
Kevin Durant and you wonder how anybody
is ever going to stop him
um he is skinny he's very skinny but you
you know and uh the track record of
players with that body type in the NBA
as as generally come with injuries but
talent wise size wise whoever wins that
lottery tonight
um is going to have the next 10 years of
their franchise and maybe even more
um changed if he can stay healthy like
he it's conceivable he is one of the
best players in the league very fast
where's the best place for him if you're
if you're Adam Silver where's the
commissioner one Victor one by Yama to
go
I mean I'm biased Dan I'm from Chicago I
think it's always great if there are
great players in Chicago and that would
be fun certainly they got enough Talent
there if you you know they have that 1.8
chance they won the Derrick Rose draft
yeah with that 1.8 chance
um I think Portland is a really
interesting one and I think Toronto is a
really interesting one
um but oh and and Charlotte by the way
it would be fun to watch him in lamelo
ball play
um as well but but you know Portland I
think you know if you had him like they
that could give that sort of late kind
of chapter Damian Lillard push that he
hasn't really had and it would provide a
bridge for them as they move that's a
great basketball City ideally look Adam
Silver would say like they'd probably
start all their home games at 4 30 so
people in New York could watch them you
know what I mean there would be maybe
some element of that
um but but I think like that that's a
place certainly I think I think Portland
would take that that they'll start the
games at 4 30.
yeah they would make that yeah and
luckily Portland has never had any bad
luck
yeah no but uh yeah I mean and look and
I'd also love to watch Greg Popovich's
potion too I think that would also be
fascinating
good to talk to you again Dan
thanks Dan I appreciate it happy belated
birthday thank you bud enjoy that carrot
cake yeah it's a vegetable so it doesn't
really matter yes it is
a vegetable play nice tonight
thank you very much that's Dan Wiki it
covers uh the LA time for the uh the
Lakers for the LA Times very funny got a
good sense of humor there